There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
Eco Styler is the brand
of gel I use all the time,
and I never knew it had
this Unicorn Glitter Gel.
It's a translucent pink color
with blue iridescent sparkles.
It's so pretty.
Running this through my hair,
I feel like you don't really
get the glittery effect.
It just kind of tinted my
hair this bluish color,
which is cool,
just not what I thought
it was going to look like.
I definitely saw the
glitter and color better
when I applied it to
brushed-back straight hair.
I think this is cute for
a little glitter moment
every once in a while.
And it actually washed
out of my hair easily.
I don't know if you guys know this,
but I'm a nail-polish freak.
So when I saw Dew by Jinsoon going viral,
I bought it immediately.
This is a milky-white polish.
It's very sheer and soft.
My nails are super stained right now,
so I was worried about how it was looking
after the first coat,
but when I went in with that second coat,
it looked really pretty,
and my nails looked so much better.
It was a little streaky in the first coat,
but the second went on totally smooth.
I do wish, though, that
this had a flat paddle brush
instead of this brush just
to make it easier to paint.
I'm sure you could find a really good
drugstore dupe for this polish,
because it is on the pricey side,
but I really like it.
This is the new Urban Decay Vice Lip Bond
glossy liquid lipstick.
So you get the glossiness of a lip gloss
and the wear of a liquid lipstick.
This is extremely pigmented.
I was really impressed by the color,
but I feel like it wasn't as shiny
as I thought it would be.
I let it dry down for 10 minutes
and kissed the back of my hand
to see if it transferred at all,
and it did, but only a little bit,
and the lipstick still looked good.
It's actually very
similar to the Maybelline
Vinyl Ink lip color I tried a while ago,
so I would probably recommend that one,
since it's cheaper and performs the same.
I am not a pot-concealer kind of person,
but I was really excited to try out
this REM Beauty Sweetener concealer.
I also got the Dreamcloud
blender to test out as well.
I scooped some up and just warmed it
on the back of my hand.
Then I used my fingers
to apply everywhere I wanted to conceal.
The concealer looks thicker than it feels.
I was actually surprised
at how lightweight it felt
when I was blending it out.
The coverage with this is amazing.
I was so shocked at
how much it covered up.
You don't need a lot at all.
I definitely put too much on,
but I really, really like this.
They also included a black and white shade
in this concealer, so you
can lighten your shade
or deepen it, which is cool.
I also really like this little sponge,
but it's not worth $15.
These NYX Ultimate Glow
Shots look so pretty
that I literally bought three of them.
They're supposed to be brightening
and give a really glowy effect.
Although these are gorgeous in the tube,
they're just really
inconsistent on the eyes.
The pigment on some is better than others,
but overall, I would say the pigment
isn't great with these on their own.
I had to build them up a lot
to get them to look like this.
They definitely work better as a topper
over other eye shadows.
I'm so torn on these
because they look so good,
but it takes a lot of
work to get them that way.